we don't have any pro-lifers here right
we don't have any pro right now we're
talking about men's rights
okay okay okay so so what's your name
ariana ariana i'm pearl nice to meet you
nice to meet you rainbow nice to meet
you
if a woman has a choice of whether or
not she wants to be a mother right
should a man have the choice of whether
or not he wants to be a father
in the name of equality yeah
yeah
i mean
everyone has their own choices of what
they want to do with their life so i
mean if a woman has
their own choice of whether they want to
be a mother or not i guess obviously
if the dad doesn't want to be in the
life of their child then
that's up to them
what do you think i'm looking confused i
thought we were talking about pro-life
approach voices no so so what we're
talking about so if i if i want to get
an abortion in the uk right i can get an
abortion up to six months
but if a man says i don't want to be a
father he's still on the hook for child
support and depending on how many kids
there are it's between 13 and 20 percent
so that incentivizes women to get kids
off of rich guys for example in the u.s
the nba players had a statement being
issued out
that
to flush their condoms because girls
were stealing them and so if we get the
right not to be mothers like shouldn't
they get the right not to be fathers so
they could sign off all their rights and
sign off on child support they don't owe
anything
i mean if the father doesn't want to be
in the child's life then like force them
to do that and they i don't think the
child would deserve that then yeah it
has bad effects on the child on the
child essentially because that causes
like psychological harm and stuff
but
at the end of the day i mean it is up to
the the father but at the end of the day
like the child's life
if the child's brought into the world
like your child's life kind of matters
and whether your child's going to be a
happy child or not or disrupted child
that's kind of up to whether you have
one
um
one kind of parent parental figure in
their life and or two yeah and i'm not
saying he shouldn't be in the la in
their life i'm just saying in the name
of equality it should be even so like he
shouldn't owe child support but i think
we agree then
like he shouldn't be on the hook for
child support because a guy can go to
jail for not paying child support
i don't know they can't they can seize
your they can seize your
i don't know that's a assets crazy i
didn't know i didn't know that that's
just a bit
that's not i don't know
i don't know i don't honestly don't know
what the laws are like in the uk i'm not
really i mean i'm from here i didn't
know that that's quite shocking that's
i don't know that's yeah
but it seems like we're all on the same
page you'd be okay with a financial
abortion for men
i wouldn't want like if i don't want my
i want my father's well my child's
father to
like if he doesn't want to be in the
father so i didn't deserve whether they
meant to pay i wouldn't want them to pay
then at that point you know yeah if he
doesn't want to be that i don't want him
to like be forced to kind of pay for
everything to do the child however like
me having that experience of like
growing up with two parents and stuff
it's definitely been a lot better than
people that i know that have grown up
like without a father and without a
mother like it's a lot different for
them do you think it's better if people
are married before they have kids oh
oh [ __ ] happens
yeah stuff i mean some people prefer to
be in like a very committed like locked
down relationship before they have
children but i mean there's a lot of
people that
aren't married but have kids
what do you think
what was the question again do you think
people it's better for the child the
children if the parents are married
before they have them
no i mean i don't
i don't see the any the impact
i don't see the impact of like
because there's a lot of people like my
parents weren't married before they had
all their kids and
they only got married
probably before their last two kids and
had about five before that and all of us
have turned out fine all of us have
you know stayed like that and whatever
there's a lot of kids out there that
their parents aren't married per se and
i don't think that has an impact on
you think it's more important just to
have both parents in the home
yeah well to have both parents there
it's more obviously ideally but ideally
i think just in those times that we are
now
you can still
you can still you can parent
you can still raise a child you don't
need obviously it's ideal and
everyone wants
it's harder obviously yeah but i don't
think that
you can still do it it's still possible
you've seen there's so many people who
have like raised their child as a single
parent and they've turned out fine yeah
and they're strong in their all the
qualities you want in a child but
statistically your kid's more at risk if
you at like every statistical advantage
disadvantage obviously yeah but like
it's life i mean
everything you won't get everything you
won't always get the marriage the dream
marriage you won't always sometimes you
have a kid before marriage and if
so happens you try your best and yeah
obviously statistically yeah you'd
better to have two parents and two
figures in the house in the home but
do you think once you get married it's
about the kids happiness and not yours
i think that should be a balance
obviously you put your kids before
yourself
but
i think even before you're married like
and you have kids before you're married
you essentially put all your energy and
stuff into your child and making your
child happy and like having the best
life for your child but there has to be
a balance between
your happiness to take over yourself yes
your personal happiness and
you know your side of life as well as
your child's side of life that has to be
that balance but
yeah essentially like
having two parents there and having one
parent there i think nowadays you know
it's not really
too big of a deal having a single parent
but then like obviously back in the day
like years and years ago like when our
parents were younger it would always be
seen as like the two parents
it was seen as like you have to have two
parents with your child it's better for
your children blah blah blah obviously
it's better but like
it's more ideal to have two parents
rather than one because
yeah that's but i mean that's like
stereotypical of like it's better and
more ideal to have
two parents but nowadays it's like you
can raise a child by yourself and be a
single parent like i've seen it alone
we're doing public interviews now okay
hi
hi public interviews hi
[Music]
you want to be interviewed we asked the
public in london their opinion on
certain topics
hi what's your name ellie
what'd you say ellie
do you have any social media you want to
plug
no no it's fine yeah so today's topic
her body her choice right
do you sense women have the right not to
be mothers if they don't want to should
men have the right not to be fathers if
they don't want to
yes in
for example
i'm not sure how her body her choice um
well what's the connection here because
that's about abortion well let's leave
that aside women have the right to give
up the child for adoption yes and yes
that is men should absolutely have the
same right to give up their child for
adoption
um because that would be really like for
like when we talk about the rights
i don't think draw parallel between
abortion and and and
men not being fathers but certainly if
you're talking about giving up the child
adoption or
disavowing yeah then men should have the
same right as women and women do have
that right why don't you think it's
comparable abortion and
child support abortion is a different
question um
it's whether the woman has a right to
abort the child or not i mean even if
you might
you might agree that a woman has a right
not to
have to physically support um with her
body i mean physically obviously
everything we do is physically but
you might agree the woman doesn't need
to physically um give life to the child
and yet you would still
think that the woman should have to feed
a child if the child is born and vice
versa you could think that the woman
shouldn't be able to kill the child
because it's it's a human being and yet
he could still support the right of the
woman or the man to give her the child
for adoption so i don't think he can i
mean he can he can be one side of one
argument and the other side the other
arguments basically
are you are you pro-life um yes that's
as i'd say broadly speaking yes do you
think it should be illegal all of the
time um
probably the best argument could be made
for